see the fbi family
share in their loss
as you may know by now this morning
agents from this office and officers
from other partner law enforcement
agencies
assembled in sunrise florida to serve
a court-ordered federal search warrant
for a violent crimes against children
investigation
fbi miami conducts search warrants
almost daily they are an essential
and important part of what we do
and we thoroughly research and
meticulously plan
to take into account any threats or
dangers
the vast majority of these warrants
occur without incident
and the investigation continues
the operation this morning in sunrise
ended tragically with the subject
opening fire
on the members of the search team
five agents were struck by gunfire
resulting in the deaths of two ages
with the other three agents sustaining
wounds of varying
severity two of the wounded agents
both shot multiple times were
transported to a local hospital
one agent had his wounds treated at the
scene
the subject is also deceased his name
will not be released
pending notification of next of kin
it takes an incredibly special person
to answer the call and do the heroic
work
of an fbi special agent it requires
self-sacrifice it requires
putting oneself in harm's way not once
but again and again
dan and laura left home this morning
to carry out the mission they signed up
for
and loved to do to keep the american
people
safe
they were valuable members of the fbi
and will forever be heroes
we will always honor their ultimate
sacrifice
dan was 36 years old
he was born in new york and joined the
fbi
in 2009 with his initial assignment
to the fbi's albany new york office
he has been assigned to fbi miami since
2017
and has worked crimes against children
violations for over six years
he survived by his wife and one child
laura was 43 years old she was born in
pueblo colorado
and joined the fbi in 2005.
her initial assignment was with the
fbi's albuquerque new mexico office
she was assigned to fbi miami in 2010
and has worked crimes against children
cases for over seven years
she is survived by her husband and two
children
the fbi is a family
and our chosen profession is fraught
with danger today
this grim reality has taken two of our
best
from our family we are saddened by their
loss
as we struggle to come to terms
with what happened however
as we grieve their loss we will continue
the mission
to protect the american people thank you
you